[Music]
miep meanwhile baby tiny love formulas
and sound like a bunch of cartoon
character with dump feels solo guys on
[ __ ] potion domination
noodles or some planets most
province foils found in lakes rivers
and oceans and cost group
the tawny factory my pellets formed raw
material for ever i plastic product
wheels and each year trillion they
already produced
melted en model intertoys bubbles band
die dance shoes to precious en offers
two
aller everywhere and they come in many
cases
multi-colored and mini shape range and
size for just  a few millimeters the wall
specs de romy visible from microscope
what the religious in the quest for ocean
domination is the ringcredible endurance
which allows them to persist in
environment for generations
die yesterday artificial make-up mix and
unable to buy your great
zo just as long  as they don't get into
the entire my wnf confused i buy
extends the problem is meanwhile have
craft the way of doing exa  ctly that
produce in several countries and shipped
to plastic manufacturing plants
the production process
carried by one of the coast of doen
chaaaaad when mistakenly trip tingle pointed
us in water
noble software free carry bike ulens
pots with those homes in  cubesearch
conduit potion systems cold shires
i drove a friend and blinder technics
pfff shires the real gathering plaids
what the heck parents or other lotion
domination be there in the pacific ocean
comparative huge die of desire and
resulting concentration evolution
is so cute teddy sloane is the great
pacific garbage patch here just like him
good company
so georgios in all times pollution what
because they do banho the great plastics
vicar and i can of other sources
besides furniture two you no time i be
seen your face wash and youtube space
again general flashback and f  you feeling
down the drain
sam also went up in the sky a garbage
patch much to do t  he white
on a noodle building on the plastic
army air and thundered large crisis of on
recycled plastic glitter black bubbles
and create bikes
transported by raf van length c
overtime nice plastic chunks stern in
2002 with little spin worn down by the
elements that made and factory  and sep
more friendly from the rough trade in
services of those microplastics
to take love all those collective i
think that's why won't chemicals check
of duty him not in the taxi
this gathering and growth a human that
die oceanic garbage patch kind shift
of the  edges size texas jumping the
size of the united states certain
soon i tornado circulated the burns
fish filter feeders
wales and performance of found it or just
come and get their daily business which
means there looking for film and
fortunately for them tank this a
[ __ ] plastic
look  -a-like physics and other hand i
think it's free what wish in chester
microplastics have very different and
terrible hbo sticking out  round in side
an email i stan that name the damage
itself with a cocktail of thaksin's de
gary
with an absolute starvation wie cash balance
labels baby in just did they never
digestive tricking a huge linter
feeling like it's continually full and
leading to eventually af when
organic and consume another
microplastics in your taxence
ardennes-pass absolute food chain and
that's how bit by bit nervous and covers
circle
grooming evermore professional wipeout
marine life
and reshape the oceans ecosystems so
factory the single the best solution how
do t-classic sahrawis and  all
together take a lifetime dat we choir
sony small collective changes blackmoor
recycling 3 plus 1 plus x with pepper and
glass and this went to agree with the
microbeads
a good couples who have steaks for
about time viewer and fewer furniture
modern apes die and carbide
page army of plastics will grow bigger
and no surrender the ocean twitch stream
keepers
want more
[Music]